alors comme on dit outre-atlantique by
popular demande bric ouest ceci étant
les vocations de votre carrière
cinématographique n'est pas moins
intéressante eddy mitchell vous avez
commencé en 62 avec les parisiennes de
jacques poitras nous dans un sketch
s'appelait et là vous en souvenez de sa
wii avec dany saval avec dany saval
michel si l'on regarde en 1964 cherchez
l'idole de michel boisrond vous
interpréter votre propre rôle d'une
fille se valent non ah c'était fou avant
bricaire non non non souvent ensemble
bruges a en 1948 la gelée pas du garros
ne juste jacquin ou si vous en 80 ans la
grand film coup de torchon de bertrand
tavernier excellent film en 83 attention
une femme peut en cacher une autre
georges lautner là aussi connu 84 ronde
de nuit de jean claude mislin eric leman
20 avec la y avait aussi cette année-là
84 morts arbitres de jean pierre mocky
en 85 autour de minuit avec bertrand
tavernier
pas mal 89 promotion canapé disait 'ca
minc à 91 la totale claude zidi 93 la
cité de la peur à la mer variant avec
les nuls 95 le bonheur est dans le pré
détiennent chez les filles adorent là
c'est la consécration
ça a été ça a été vraiment bien reconnu
comme un acteur de cinéma à ce moment là
enfin je sais pas si on a reconnu
non m'a collé le camp de césar
voila voila tu n'as pas de mai le 3l
bagnols
dommage excuse moi mais c'est dommage
parce que c'est toi qui l'avais repartir
gecina alors ses fans au satimo
officielle à l asim pas non plus une
maladie honteuse bravo est alors en 2002
là c'est le drame
exactement lovely rita de stéphane
clavier avec christian clavier
là les arbres les impôts 1
mais non je suis pas d'accord parce que
le film taf non plus avait du sang des
jeux des qualités d un certain temps les
stars viennent culot mais lui ça ça
marche c'est vraiment tout le monde a
cru que la carrière de questions clavier
était morte à ce moment là d un non non
je pense pas enfin nous prenons ces deux
billets ça arrive ya du film comme ça
qu'ils pas mal qui vont dans le mur
n'est ce pas j'ai pas envie de parler de
ça donc ça arrive à aux plus grandes
entre 2001 et en 2006 donc cette année
un printemps à paris de jacques bral
voilà qui vous amène ce soir on a gelé
en venir voilà alors empruntant à paris
avec vous et sagamore stévenin pierre
santini pascale arbillot la
participation de gérard jugnot
oui voilà ça sort le 1er mars alors je
vais faire le pitch voulait suite à un
casse organisée par sega mort steve n'a
un jeune chien fou spécialiste des coups
foireux vous taper cinq ans de prison
exane et quand vous retrouver la liberté
vous avec une seule idée en tête vous
mettre au vert mais c'est également
réapparaît avec une affaire en or
évidemment s'emparer des bijoux d'une
riche bourgeoise avec la complicité de
son assureur
mais l'assureur trompeur et sagamore
stévenin tombe amoureux de sa victime
voilà alors cinq ans après ses deux
nouveaux la galère qui recommence wali
suis pas très intelligent que je vais
c'est vrai vous êtes vraiment
j'aimerais c'est un personnage que j'ai
vraiment pris j'ai pris beaucoup de
plusieurs l'a interprété par ce que
parce que c'est un personnage qui c'est
qui va dans le mur et il est incapable
de l'éviter il est incapable de résister
il a des codes qui ne fonctionne plus du
tout même et justement il se trouve face
à ce jeune zahia mortellement qui
d'ailleurs tire son épingle du jeu dans
ce film est très bien et
qu'effectivement comble je dire pour un
cambrioleur pour un casseur tombe
amoureux de la victime donc ça se fume
ça devait le faire alors oui vous êtes
dans le film à un truand à l'ancienne
son flingue
contrairement à licques défouraille pour
un rien ce que vous nous avez une loi
c'est à dire on est en retard mais avec
l'ancien deux époques deux visions du
métier
alors pourquoi dites vous que ce film
c'est un ovni dans le cinéma français
quand ils sont revenus c'est parce que
ils rentrent pas dans les critères
actuels cinéma français bon c'est pas et
les mythes chaîne dans brice de nice 2
quoi est certain que ça quand les jambes
et je critique pas d'ailleurs nous et
donc c'est vrai que faire un un polar
simple simple direct costaud comme de
commis les faits à des personnages qui
sont tous timbre et c'est pas courant